it's great to be joined today by
Elizabeth kerbed halket who's the James
Irvine chair in Urban and Regional
Planning and professor of public policy
at the University of Southern California
seamos she most recently is the author
of the sum of small things a theory of
the aspirational class which I recently
read with great interest Elizabeth let's
start a little bit with consumption and
how in society over time how consumption
and wealth or status of other kinds is
displayed if we go back a few hundred
years generally speaking how was wealth
noticed in in others so if we go back to
the person who was my inspiration for
this book Thorsten Veblen he wrote a
book in 1899 called the theory of the
leisure class and in it he looks
particularly at the leisure class
although he did make comments on all of
society and how different socioeconomic
groups revealed status and his argument
was that material goods that did not
have additional utility with the way in
which people revealed wealth so his very
famous example is out of the silver
spoon which you know at the time
wouldn't have been better than an
aluminum one in terms of function it
wouldn't have even looked that much
different but there was it was slightly
prettier and what it really revealed was
that you could afford a silver spoon and
so initially statist was a was revealed
through and displayed through stuff and
now he's actually been the case for a
long time and it still is it's not like
that way of showing status has been
completely eradicated but being palpable
because you know with first the
Industrial Revolution and then the
manufacturing economy of the 20th
century a lot of us have a lot of stuff
so it's less valuable for social
positioning what about something like at
the time and we'll get to how this has
changed but just to sort of set the
scene I want to dig into education a
little bit I mean at the time was
education so
things that had that that even had
utility in the same way that it does
today in the context of the job market
or how was education seen at this time
so that's a really great question I'm
really fascinated with the role of
education in society and how its evolved
so again referring to Dublin Dublin saw
university education as conspicuous
leisure so you didn't go to you know
Oxford and study Greek if you had to get
a job okay it was incredibly luxurious
to to go to an elite institution just to
learn and empirically you can see this
because a lot of you know jobs even in
the 20th century when we had the
emergence of a middle class where people
were making really good money um you
know through jobs they wasn't just
simply like a an upper class or an
aristocracy but you actually had this
emergence of people who had you know
real money and made and made it even
they didn't require a college education
now the precise stuff I don't have at
the top of my head but it was it was
under 10% for both men and women in the
mid 20th century under 10% of them had a
college degree and now we're dealing
with something like 33% of the
population so this gets back to your
original question which is how has
education evolved as a signal in terms
of signaling so I think initially
education was absolutely a part of
conspicuous consumption conspicuous
leisure you didn't need it on you you
did it if you you you were able to
enroll in university if you had the time
the money and you didn't need to get a
job today it's different right so we
live in a ostensibly and I emphasize
ostensibly meritocratic society and
college is really important and elite
universities are really the ticket to
the club so whilst of course the parents
really proud when their kid gets into
MIT or Harvard or one of these top elite
university
it's also a necessity for upward
mobility to go to university and so what
I've seen in the data is I've actually
moved education into inconspicuous
consumption
people pay for it because they know it's
their way to make it in the world now
and so it's not so much about status
even though that's a nice by-product but
it is actually about how social mobility
is reproduced and and it's expensive now
and people really have to work to send
their kids to college and so that's
become an enormous chunk of we're
certainly on the upper middle classes
are devoting resources so in part two of
the interview we're going to get into
some of the broader economic impacts on
class and inequality of some of what you
described in the earlier part of the
book the sum of small things but I want
to talk with you a little bit about some
of the new inconspicuous consumption and
and what's interesting to me about some
of these activities and this includes
from the book again examples that you
give free-range organic chicken versus
you know the normal chicken you get at
the grocery store or heirloom tomatoes
versus the other kinds of tomatoes or
organic cotton shirt
where you know the you know where the
cotton was farmed and what the children
of the farmers are studying in school or
whatever the case may be you only really
understand those as signifiers of status
if you are already sort of part of the
in-group to at least some degree right I
mean somebody who is not in the world
where you even understand about organic
cotton or heirloom tomatoes they're not
really going to be impressed when they
find out that their neighbor has
heirloom tomatoes or organic cotton
shirts right well my parents would not
be impressed with any of those things
right
so you know Dave my parents are Irish
immigrants they they live in rural
Pennsylvania and those would not be
markers of status for them and you know
they're from a different generation but
I also think that they geographically
speak to the fact that some of these
kind of bubbles of aspirational class
are geographically specific and also
they really are it
sort of insiders baseball you know I
mean they're they matter for the people
who are following it but but they are
are more or less irrelevant to other
people and what does that tell us about
I guess you know we still have
conspicuous consumption in 2017 and it's
more along the lines of the car you
drive or if you have a particular type
of watch or whatever the case may be
what are the sort of most notable
distinguishing factors in how modern-day
conspicuous versus inconspicuous
consumption is seen by society at large
so again another really terrific
question so one of the things that's
important is it's not like conspicuous
consumption and conventional luxury
goods have totally disappeared I mean
you know people are still spending a lot
of money on luxury cars designer
handbags are still very popular you know
so so these you know and of course
watches are too um so it's not it's not
that they have disappeared and and the
identity in which people form around
these things is also more fluid so you
know there are all sorts of
contradictions right like you you care
about our organic food and you um and
you drive a diesel car but you have a
you know 2,000 dollar handbag okay I
mean that that person exists in the
world right so so I think that that you
have this kind of blending what makes I
think the aspirational class unusual and
I think a new class of people is there
is a new way in which they form their
social group which is through the subtle
um you know kind of you know passing
information that they care in about
organic food and free-range this and
caring about the environment and in a
way you might say that they're not a
million miles from what David Brooks
called
on Bobo's you know I don't know if you
remember the book Bobo's in paradise
yeah but the thing I think is really
different about this group is there's
there's a real lack of
self-consciousness I mean these are
these are this is a group of people who
feel they're doing right on that they
are making good decisions for their
children that they're making good
decisions for the environment on they're
not having they're not uncomfortable
with their social position they in fact
think that unlike perhaps previous um
elites that they're actually doing
better in the world they're not just
buying luxury handbags they do prefer
their NPR tote you know they're not all
really wealthy on what they what they
are all rich in is cultural capital and
I think that that's the really
distinguishing characteristic for them
we're going to pick it up there in part
two of our interview with Elizabeth
Couric halket we've been speaking about
her book with some of small things a
theory of the aspirational class we're
continuing our conversation now with
Elizabeth caried halket who is the james
irvine chair in Urban and Regional
Planning and professor of public policy
at the University of Southern California
we've been speaking about her recent
book the some of small things a theory
of the aspirational class so Elizabeth
yesterday we sort of explained the ways
in which the the elites the the new
elites of sorts of 2017 can sometimes
signal status and it's increasingly
through inconspicuous forms of
consumption and we talked about some of
them in order to get us into the ways in
which this is going to impact inequality
going forward I want to talk a little
bit about time and the availability of
time because as I read your book that
seems to be sort of an underlying theme
in many of these more inconspicuous
signals of status like for example
breastfeeding for longer during
motherhood which is something that
requires far more available time in
order to do Pilates and yoga classes
particularly between 9:00 and 5:00
Monday through Friday grocery shopping
at 11:00 a.m. on a Tuesday this sort of
activity so can you talk a little bit
first about how we should see the value
of this free time in modern society so
as and I think it was Thomas Frank who
actually might've been Robert Frank who
studied how much
people had and he found that wealthier
men and women actually had the least
time well wealthiest wealthy women had
the least time of all and so what is
interesting is as we've evolved into a
knowledge economy um and all of these
people with their you know pedigree and
and under an elite degrees from top
universities go into the workforce they
they aren't a leisure class at all okay
so today's elite for the most part or
not they are working really long hours
they're working 60 hours if you're a
lawyer you're working on the weekends if
you're a doctor you're doing on-call
shifts sometimes on so you have a group
of people who are making a lot of money
who are without question elite and yet
they they the thing that they have
traded off for that money in that
prestigious time and so what happens is
that that disposable income go towards
getting some of the back and so that's
where you actually when you look at the
patterns of upper income spending that
you see people spending on things that
give that back they they spend money on
housekeepers on gardeners they spend
money on you know not nannies and it you
know at home childcare that allows some
flexibility and and they also spend
money on experiences which is you know
using time in a way that that allows
them to you know recharge and and and
and get the most out of it
and then your your point about
breastfeeding is really interesting
because um that of course requires a few
different things right so it requires a
lot of time it requires it requires
either having fantastic maternity leave
and being usually paid for it on or and
or it requires a partner who is making a
lot of money so that you can stay home
and breastfeed your child and so all of
these things are implicit signals of
time and you're examples of Pilates and
grocery shopping at um you know unusual
hours of the day are also signals that
you have it and they are implicitly on
revealing of social position because
and if you're an hourly worker you're
not going to be able to go grocery
shopping at 11:00 in the morning you're
definitely not taking a exercise class
at that time if you're an hourly worker
who doesn't get maternity leave how do
you figure out the breastfeeding thing
and and also how do you how do you pump
at work if that's not encouraged and
that's not you're not in a company that
really supports that so a lot of these
signals really are about time and
flexibility when we look at the big
picture of this move towards
inconspicuous of designators of status
or wealth can we assess the
multi-generational impact on income and
wealth inequality of that is that is
there is there a clear sort of answer to
that for you if we compare you know how
are how would someone's grandchild be
impacted by the fact that they had
silver instead of steel spoons versus
how would they be impacted by increased
spending on the types of activities
you're talking about so I said that
that's a that's a really great
juxtaposition of how fade is good in
need two different centuries two
different time periods on impact future
generations so you know leisure class
spending on didn't inherently on impact
social mobility I mean these may be
people who have lots of wealth and they
pass it on to generation after
generation okay so it's eight years the
kids with the silver spoon on you know
become adults with bigger silver spoons
and children with silver spoon but it's
not the the actual on display of status
and the and the mechanisms by which
that's revealed don't we produce the
privilege if that makes sense the today
is very different if you're able to put
your kid into preschool early and you're
able to put your children into either a
fantastic public school district which
means you probably paid an awful lot of
money for your house particularly if you
live in urban America or you are able to
put your child through private school
which these days you know runs twenty to
thirty plus thousand dollars for
kindergarten
and these are our
eight schools which then feed into great
high schools which then are really great
you know preparatory schools for sending
them to the most elite universities and
then your your parent who's able to
write checks for those top schools and
top universities which now can be up to
$60,000 a year after tax I you know that
that is a reproduction that symbol of
social economic position actually is a
functional reproduction of privilege as
well so it's not the handbag or the
spoon which is simply like here it is
look how rich I am it actually has an
ongoing functional component to it you
mentioned urban centers I know you do an
entire chapter on this but I'd love for
you to talk a little bit about the role
of cities within this aspirational class
theory that you write about so I operate
on two levels so um first of all you
know class identification often involves
a group right so you can absolutely be
you know eating your heirloom tomatoes
and your free-range chickens in a small
town and no one knows and people do do
that absolutely for sure but part of
this of the identification of a class is
the fact that there's a group of people
doing this at the same time and who on
some even if it's a tacit implicit level
you're connecting with so everyone's
showing up it's a farmers market
they're not bragging about their organic
peaches but they're all they're buying
that right so you have this kind of
group identification cities become
centers of the aspirational class and
it's consumption a few reasons for this
one is that cities have really evolved
from being centers of production of
things as they were in the you know late
nineteenth and middle 20th century to
being production of ideas on as a
product of that they've attracted these
you know extremely uneducated on you
know Richard Florida calls in the
creative class on this group of people
and these people have a lot of money so
they need places to spend their money
right so cities have also become centers
of consumption
um the fact that so many of these you
know people who work in knowledge
industries can she be a part of this
aspirational class means that a lot of
cities tend to cater to their needs
so you see tons of farmers markets and
artisanal coffee and Whole Foods and you
know you know little boutiques with
curated um you know made in you know Los
Angeles for example t-shirts because
these are the people are going to spend
them so the spent spend on them so so
cities are have become centers of
consumption and I would say in the last
10 to 15 years they become centers of
this particular kind of spending to
we've been speaking about the book the
some of small things a theory of the
aspirational class the books author has
been joining me Elizabeth curd halket I
highly recommend the book a very very
interesting read and Elizabeth I can't
thank you enough for talking to us about
it today oh it's been a pleasure thank
you for having me